hello what is up guys my name is the
chair now and welcome to another video
as you probably noticed I look a bit
different today because I got that
haircut that I was telling you about in
the last video
well anyway today I'm this beautiful
place called the Hanging Rock and today
we've got a little bit video about a new
series or 205 hey what's up guys my name
is Jonah welcome to another video so
cold I'm on I'm at Hanging Rock right
now and it's like 10 degrees but Bob's
on the update video so well since the
last update video but today we got
something pretty exciting he's talking
about when we talk me about so the
staples loss series has been going on
for about six months and the number one
question that I keep getting about that
is cool you're showing us all of these
concepts and we are learning the
language but how do you apply this
knowledge to actually write programs and
write software and make games and make
game engines and all of that stuff now
that I know it's a cost for us now that
I know how to write C++
how do I actually make a program with it
and that's kind of what the new series
that are going to come on my channel are
really going to focus on so there's kind
of two two main series that I want to
introduce both should start sometime
this year
and they're both kind of going to
complement each other in the sense that
I need to like my ultimate goal with C++
kind of from scratch right so everything
we've been learning about C++ everything
we've been learning about optimization
and performance and all that we're gonna
put that into creating a really really
good efficient game engine is capable of
some really nice graphics and we'll make
a game from now that's kind of the end
goal that's the long term strategy if
you will before this channel and all the
series coming from them from that but
the first step is probably going to be
to learn about a graphics API so if
there's a big graphics programming how
does that work I've never really done a
series on that I did like a flappy bird
series and I had the Sparky game engine
series but those were there like the
foot the the flappy bird series was kind
of teaching OpenGL but that was in Java
so like
just just put that Hawkeye [ __ ] away
but then with the flatwoods with the
spocky series that was more or less of
me kind of making an engine life in
front of you guys and streaming in and
it was like an hour per video and it
wasn't very well explained I think I
don't know I just didn't like it too
much so my goal is going to be there
actually create a graphic series
teaching opengl we're going to start
with opengl but we may get to DirectX
and Vulcan eventually Malcolm's probably
probably going to come last because the
drivers right now are are terrible and
it's just nowhere near mature enough so
I don't really want to go into evolve in
the series but DirectX 11 is really
really good DirectX 12 might be a bit
too low level we might we'll deal with
DirectX a bit later but I still feel
that the if you had to implement one
graphics API into your engine
Vulcan is a bit too risky bit too early
to go with so I would still probably
pick up in jail so I think we're gonna
start with OpenGL I mean most of the
concepts are gonna transfer to Vulcan
and DirectX anyway by the way but we're
gonna start with OpenGL and we're going
to kind of work our way to the other
api's but the OpenGL ster is gonna cover
everything I mean everything about
modern OpenGL and how to write a
graphics engine in OpenGL and we'll get
to like physically based rendering
deferred rendering you know
post-processing effects just everything
like we're gonna make some real like
triple a quality graphics with this
believe me so that's gonna be really
exciting because I loved graphics
programming so I can't wait to get into
that and the main goal of that series
though is not going to be to make some
kind of engine right we're not going to
create a graphics engine we're going to
create a very very very small framework
and mainly consisting of stuff like
maths and utility classes but we're not
going to make an engine like oh I want
to show you guys how to actually write
the OpenGL code and how to call the
OpenGL API when you want to do something
and we'll kind of end up hopefully
implementing every example in one file
instead of having to kind of split it up
into an engine I don't want to make an
engine from that at all why if I mean
rocks in your shoes love it come on
look do you mix it up so I just wanted
to make that absolutely clear that we're
not going to make a game engine or a
graphics engine out of OpenGL that's
what the game engine series is going to
be for it's going to heavily reference
the OpenGL series during the game engine
series when we do end up having to deal
with graphics I'm not going to I'm not
going to try and kind of explain
absolutely everything like how triangles
are rendered on your screen because I'll
just be able to reference the OpenGL
series which is why I also think that
the OpenGL series should probably come
first I don't want to talk too much
about the game engine stories just yet
because again the first step is probably
gonna be to do that OpenGL series I do
still want to maybe have both of them
running concurrently once we get up to a
certain point in the OpenGL series C++
series will still continue obviously by
the way but um having like maybe you
know one episode of each series per week
so that'll be like three videos a week
or something I think I could probably
manage that and that's probably a good
kind of level of diversity and people
can kind of tune in to the ones they
want or all three all three is gonna be
the best choice of Z but yeah ultimately
the game engine series is going to be
more about how to implement kind of what
we've learned in OpenGL into an actual
game engine environment and a game
engine series will cover multiple
graphics API so we'll probably have
OpenGL and DirectX and bulk and like you
know all of them in the game engine so
we can kind of pick which one you want
to render with and obviously that's
going to matter on different platforms
because if you're on on Mac or maybe on
like an Android phone or an or an iPhone
you you're not gonna be able to use
DirectX so you can pick another API
anyway it's gonna be cool it's not a
huge project I'm hopefully gonna have a
lot of community involvement as well
yeah I'm really excited about the whole
thing to be honest I know let's look at
what else I wrote in my nose oh yeah so
yeah once once per week at a minimum
it's gonna be for the for the two series
when I start with the opengl series
maybe we can kind of rattle off a few of
the basic episodes quickly in like one
week I can make you know just a few of
them per week or something and then
eventually come back to doing one per
week when it gets kind of more hardcore
and
as well as having the the game the game
engine serious happening as well and the
main point of the game engine serious is
obviously to make a good game engine you
have to make a game because the game is
like you'll be testing the engine with
the game so we're definitely going to
make a pretty like interesting game
right now my thoughts are kind of making
something like Minecraft and the reason
I want to make something like Minecraft
is because it's a good mix of kind of
like you don't need to be an artist to
make Minecraft but on a technical level
minecraft demonstrates a lot of
challenges such as you know huge huge
kind of levels and data and dealing with
all of that efficient rendering you know
batching in an efficient way and you can
implement pretty much any graphics you
want into there obviously we're gonna go
with some cool like physically based
rendering and stuff like that and many
kind of dynamic lights and shadows and
all that stuff and then we can obviously
add like 3d models to Minecraft and all
of that but what I mean is I'm not an
artist and I don't really think that I
could work with an artist to make
something like this because I'm probably
gonna have enough time and it's just not
like obviously I have a full-time job so
it's gonna be a bit difficult for me to
do this if I was working with an artist
and I'm not a very good artist so making
something like Minecraft is gonna be
pretty simple from the art point of view
but it will still look good because I
can focus like all the kind of looking
good efforts like YES on lighting and
stuff like that
alright so that's pretty much it for the
update video let me know what your
thoughts are below I think I am gonna
start that that opengl series first
though I was contemplating starting the
game engine series first and maybe not
focusing on graphics and all of that but
I think that logically it makes sense to
start the graphics series first and then
to kind of you know bring down bring
down onto the game engine series once we
actually reached a point of having
enough graphics knowledge to start
writing like a basic kind of rendering
API I guess and some kind of some kind
of API for rendering in the game engine
but obviously this series are gonna be
huge
specifically the game engine series
probably several years worth of stuff
there hopefully we can get something up
and running as quick as possible and
then we'll refine it over and over again
just so that I don't bore you guys with
setting up like a year's worth of code
we even see something nice on the screen
so leave your thoughts about what I've
said in the comment section below
because obviously I want to kind of
collaborate with you guys to bring you
guys the best content that you can
possibly get and to teach you like
everything I know in an efficient way so
let me know what your thoughts are and
yeah I'll see you guys in the next video
goodbye
no do it again the whole thing yeah
thing no I can't just like you that
would be a jump cut anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this video and I'll see you guys
in the next one
good bye
[ __ ] clothes like over an hour ago and
we thought that like the closing time
with more people not being allowed in
but apparently you're supposed to leave
before the closing time who would have
thought that right
they almost turned our car but they
didn't because it's there